NICHOLAS GARNIER: Hello,
everybody.
My name is Nicholas.
BURCU DOGAN: And I'm Burcu
NICHOLAS GARNIER: We are from
the Google Drive Developer
Relations team, live
from Zurich.
And we are here today to talk
to you about cross-client
authorization on Android
and the web.
So Burcu, could you basically
explain to us in what this is
interesting to the user?
Who should use that?
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah, most the
time, your projects may have
more than two components,
the web and the mobile.
So the authorization experience
between cross is
different applications
always is troubling.
So we listened to developer
feedback.
And we wanted to improve the
experience for the users.
And back in May, we introduced
two features that will
actually help you a
little bit more.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So can you
just give me a few examples of
architectures, basically, that
developers have where they
should use this?
For example, they have an
Android app and a server side
component, they need to talk.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah,
for example.
You want to delegate some task
to the server side such as
processing data on the server
side into the mobile
application.
So in this case, your web server
needs to be authorized
as well as your mobile app.
But just imagine that your user
discovered the app on a
store, and downloaded it, and
authorized it, and haven't
touched to the web component.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah,
haven't authorized
yet from the web.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
So what you basically can do is
to just retrieve an access
token, which is likely
to live not for long,
just an hour or so.
So if you would like to delegate
some work, some
background, offline work to
the service itself, it's
basically not so possible.
I have seen some bad
implementations that people
were trying to exchange
the access token
with the web server.
But from a security point
of view, it's not good.
And also, the tokens are
not living long.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
So basically, this is for
developers that have both a
web component-- it could be
a separate app or just a
server-side backend to
run some process--
and also, for example,
an Android app.
And those two need to authorize
in a very nice,
UX-friendy way, basically.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
True.
NICHOLAS GARNIER:
Is that correct?
And you also want to avoid just
passing a simple access
token, which you could have done
before, using the regular
play services authorization.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Right.
BURCU DOGAN: This was
one of the features.
The other feature we have
released was, we resolve the
user's identity with no sign-in
on the Android app, if
you are authorized for
the web component.
Just imagine, in this case, that
you have a web app, and
the user is given the
right permissions.
And once he wants to switch
back to the mobile app, he
needs to go through, again,
the authorization.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So you
want to avoid the user
to authorize twice--
once on the web app, and then
they want you to try your
Android app.
And they have to authorize
again.
BURCU DOGAN: Again.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So this is a
way to have the user already
authorized, right?
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So maybe we
could have a look on your
computer in details the
documentation, so we could
explain how this works,
basically.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah, sure.
Let's go through our
documentation first.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So first,
let me explain to the
developers here who
are watching us.
The documentation can be
found in a few places.
We are from the Google
Drive SDK team.
So we have written a Google
Drive-specific documentation
on the Google Drive
SDK, online doc.
You can go there.
It's fairly generic, so you
could apply this to more--
BURCU DOGAN: Other Google
APIs, basically.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Other
Google APIs.
BURCU DOGAN: With different
scopes.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yes, with
different scopes, just by
simply applying different
scopes.
But there's also a documentation
on the Android
documentation itself, which
doesn't contain a lot of code
samples, which is why we have
augmented it by releasing this
documentation here.
So maybe you could show
us where that page is?
BURCU DOGAN: It's under
authorized requests.
And we have this section, Choose
a Platform, where we
will go to the Android one.
And there's a new section called
Cross-Client Identity.
And this basically explains
implementation
for both of the features.
So let's first start with how
to retrieve a code for the
server, so the server can
get offline access.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
So this is basically when the
user goes on the Android
application first and you want
to authorize your server side
to be able to do either, for
example, long-term processing
because in the--
before we even launched that
feature, the Play services
only allowed you to fetch an
access token, which is only
valid for one hour.
So you could have passed this
to your server side.
But as we'll see in just a
second, this feature now
allows you to pass longer-term
tokens, for example, the
refresh token.
It allows your server side to
fetch a refresh token, which
grants unlimited access in
time to your server side
components.
BURCU DOGAN: So if you're an
Android developer already, you
should be familiar with how
to get an access token.
Actually, all of the tokens
are bundled in this
[INAUDIBLE] core.
So we take care of how--
[?
NICHOLAS GARNIER: With the
Android Play services.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah,
Play services.
So what we provide to you is
this utility interface to get
an access token.
So instead, what you were
basically doing here was--
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So let
me just explain.
Before, if you're already using
the Play services to
authorize, you would simply
pass the scopes, the OS2
scopes of the APIs that you
needed access to, for example,
the Google Drive API, the
Google+ API, et cetera.
BURCU DOGAN: So yeah, you
were providing the
account and the scopes.
And you were retrieving
an access token.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
BURCU DOGAN: In this case, what
we have done, instead of
just passing the scopes, you
need to pass another magic
string, let's say.
And we will just give
you a code, instead
of an access token.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yes.
So basically, you've
highlighted this on the screen.
BURCU DOGAN: I've
highlighted it.
And you need to format the
scope, like OAuth2 column
server, client ID.
And you need to append your web
apps client ID here, which
is basically in this format.
And it's available on--
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Typically,
in this format.
So one very important point
for developers.
Your two client IDs, the Android
client ID and also
your web client ID,
need to be in the
same API console project.
This is how we detect
that those two
client IDs are linked.
BURCU DOGAN: That's right.
And still, you need to pass
the list of scopes again.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: A
list of scopes.
Yeah.
So I see, up there in red,
could you highlight it?
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: There is
currently a little limitation.
BURCU DOGAN: We have
a warning here.
We currently require +log-in to
be included in the scope.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
So one of the scopes need to
be the +log-in scopes, for
this authorization
feature to work.
This is currently, basically,
mandatory in the current
implementations of the system.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
Otherwise, you will not be
able to retrieve a code.
That's true.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: All right.
And then the API should
basically allow you to get--
BURCU DOGAN: A code.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: An
authorization code, which you
can pass to your server side.
And the server side will
exchange, using the--
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
It's like you will continue the
flow by retrieving here,
by just making a [? post ?]
request, as regular, and
retrieve it.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
This is regular.
OAuth2, by the way.
You exchange the authorization
code for a refresh token and
an access token.
BURCU DOGAN: So there's one
thing I need to tell.
Instead of passing the
redirect URL--
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So
typically, with
the regular web flow--
let me explain.
BURCU DOGAN: Just ignore--
NICHOLAS GARNIER: One of the
parameters here that you need
to pass in the request
is your redirect URI.
Except here, there's no redirect
URI, since it's all
done on Android using
a native interface.
So you basically simply skip
it in the request.
That's what I see.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: And
this should work.
You exchange the authorization
code and get your refresh
token, basically.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
So they will basically
retrieve [INAUDIBLE]
access and [INAUDIBLE].
So the server side can
make its request
on behalf of itself.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Mm-hm.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Cool.
BURCU DOGAN: So, yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Is there
anything else that
the user can do?
BURCU DOGAN: Of course.
So let's switch back to
the other feature.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: I knew you
were going to say that.
BURCU DOGAN: So in this case,
let's take a look how to
resolve user identity
without sign in.
It's again a magic string.
Instead of passing the
regular scope--
NICHOLAS GARNIER: In which case
should developers use
this feature again?
BURCU DOGAN: So you
want to know--
NICHOLAS GARNIER: This is a bit
different from the one we
just talked about.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
So you want to know
who the user is.
You want to know what's the
user's email address.
You need to identify the user
somehow on your server.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So you need to
identify using the server.
That's, for example, if you are
sending data that you need
to save for your user.
And you want to pass also, in a
secure way, the identity of
the user, so that your server
side can save that data for
the right user.
Is that it?
BURCU DOGAN: Mm-hm.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: OK.
BURCU DOGAN: So in order to,
again, pass in the regular
scope string, we have, this
time, this string, which is
all this column, server,
again, the client ID.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So basically,
this works the same
way that we've just seen?
By using the Play services?
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
You still need to uncall
Google Auth [INAUDIBLE]
token, the same interface.
And it will basically--
NICHOLAS GARNIER: But you just
pass a different magic string.
OK.
BURCU DOGAN: So, yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So what
does this give you?
BURCU DOGAN: What it gives
us is a JSON web token.
It's actually different
[INAUDIBLE].
And you need to pass it
to your web servlet.
NICHOLAS GARNIER:
It's encrypted?
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah,
it's encrypted.
I'm sorry.
You need to pass it
to your server.
And your server needs
to decrypt it again.
And it basically has these
attributes, ISS, OUD, AZP, and
the user's email.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: OK.
Cool.
So this is basically an
encrypted token containing the
user email, which then
you can use to
identify your developer.
BURCU DOGAN: That's it.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So yeah, I
just wanted to point out
developers to compare this to
what was already existing
before we launched this.
Basically, in the past, you
could have done this by
passing an access token that
gives you access to the user
info API, for example,
or [? our open ?]
[? AD ?] endpoints.
This is basically nicer, because
the server side is
going to save one
fetch request.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: You can simply
get the GWT in your
request, decrypt it.
There is no external request.
Your server side is going to
know already, right away, what
the email of the user is.
Whereas, if you pass an access
token to your server side, you
would have had to fetch--
which is also quite secure-- but
it would have had to fetch
the user identity.
BURCU DOGAN: So it's an
additional request.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: It's an
And also, probably also,
verify the access token
itself, see if it's actually
been issued by the app, to
avoid forged requests.
So this is a very nice
way to do this.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
But you need to be careful.
First of all, you have to make
sure that you are transmitting
this token on HTTPS,
instead of HTTP.
And you to make sure that ISS
is [INAUDIBLE] so google.com
is easy to fake.
So you have to make sure that
[INAUDIBLE] is declined on
your web app.
And the other one is the client
ID of your Android app.
And then you can trust that
user email is actually
[INAUDIBLE]
Google endpoints [INAUDIBLE].
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Cool.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: But this is
a nice tool, so you avoid a
few requests.
So you're able to do this a lot
faster and develop more
efficiently on your backend.
BURCU DOGAN: So we actually
have a sample that already
implements a [INAUDIBLE].
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
So this is our GitHub repository
of the Google Drive
team, basically.
BURCU DOGAN: So we have
examples or--
NICHOLAS GARNIER: [INAUDIBLE]
samples and--
BURCU DOGAN: Libraries.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
BURCU DOGAN: And so we published
[? +client ?]
to Android almost a
week ago, maybe.
So it basically demonstrates
two cases.
Let's quickly go through
the code.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So this sample
is a bit more complete
to what you'll find in the
documentation, which skips a
lot of [INAUDIBLE], just shows
you the bare bone of the code.
This is almost like
a working--
BURCU DOGAN: Example
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Example of
the usage of these two
features that we've just seen.
BURCU DOGAN: So as I mentioned,
in order to get a
token, you need to [INAUDIBLE]
to a user account name.
In this case, what I'm doing,
firstly, in the sample, is I'm
starting an activity to
pick a user here.
So there should be multiple
users on the phones.
A user can switch
back and forth
between different accounts.
So once a user has picked
one, we are here.
And this callback, what I'm
doing is actually starting two
asynchronous tasks to retrieve
first the exchange code and
the JSON web token.
So let's go what we're
doing here and see
what we're doing here.
So in order to retrieve a
code, what we do is just
formatting this code
in the format
that I mentioned before.
So instead of an access token,
what it will do is to retrieve
a code, right?
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Authorization
code, yeah, [?
to know what to authorize
your code. ?]
BURCU DOGAN: By the way,
your user is not--
having given you enough
permissions before, it will
show a user recoverable
auth exception.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
So this is if the user has
never granted that
authorization to the app,
neither on the web version of
your web app?
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah, yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Nor on
the Android version.
BURCU DOGAN: And for the scopes,
you have passed.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: For that
exact list of scopes.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
So what you can do here is
that this exception is an
[? intent. ?]
So regularly it's the same
while you're trying to
retrieve an access
token, right?
If the user hasn't given you
enough permissions, you start
a new activity for the dialog.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
Basically, the user will get
a nice native authorization
dialog on their Android device
where they can simply approve
or reject the authorization that
the app is asking for.
BURCU DOGAN: That's true.
So once a user has given access,
I'm going to check if
the user has really given
access to us or not.
So in this case, if it's
yes, I'm actually
retrying the same request.
So in this case, instead of this
exception, I will be able
to retrieve the code.
And what I'm basically doing
here is just, put it on the
application's UI.
But you need to pass it
to your web server.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
That's when you do an HTTP
request to send it to your
server side, which will exchange
it, basically.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
I know another case in order to
retrieve a JSON web token,
what you do is to format
the scope.
In this case here, I'm
highlighting it.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
And again, catching the
exception with this.
If it's never been approved
before, if the authorization
has never been granted before,
and it probably works the same
way as that.
Correct?
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: OK.
BURCU DOGAN: So yeah,
it will return back
to this line again.
And I will be retrying again.
So yeah.
And it will retrieve
a JSON web token.
And you can pass it to
your web server.
And your web server
can resolve the
identity of the user.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yep.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah?
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Cool.
So yeah.
Maybe we're done with
the documentation.
BURCU DOGAN: This quick
sample code.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: And the
simple code here.
So basically, let's talk about,
in general, what is it
good for, what are the
advantages of using that
feature against what was
possible before.
So in my understanding--
and you can let me know
if you agree--
this is very nice, because
it's going to provide a
completely Android native
experience to your users,
while still keeping two
client IDs in sync.
So what developers were doing
before, previously to this,
some were using a web view on
their Android app to start an
OAuth2 flow using the
[INAUDIBLE] of their web apps
to have a common client ID,
which wasn't very nice,
because the user had to log-in
again inside the web flow.
There, you'll get a very, very
nice native experience because
of those native pop-ups.
The user is already signed in
to his Android machine.
He can very, very
quickly approve.
And he will still get
auto-approval on the website,
if you have also
web components.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
It's a seamless experience for
the user, first of all.
And we enabled [INAUDIBLE]
was basically not available
before.
So yeah, that's basically it.
And Google used a sample, so
we're actually looking for
developer feedback.
These two tokens are a little
bit more experimental.
And maybe, in the future, we
can expand the OAuth2 spec.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
It's basically like a workaround
around the OAuth2
specs, because OAuth2 has never
really defined a way to
do cross-client authorization.
BURCU DOGAN: That's true.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: So this
is our implementation,
our way to do it.
We hope you like it.
If you'd like to give us some
feedback, please have a look
at our code sample on our Github
Google Drive page.
You can leave comments
there, I guess.
BURCU DOGAN: Yeah.
You can file issues, if
there's a problem.
And you can contribute back.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Yeah.
We'll be happy to hear what you
have to say about this.
All right.
Is there anything else
that you'd like
to talk about, Burcu?
BURCU DOGAN: I think
that's it.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: OK, cool.
Then thanks, very much,
guys, or everybody.
BURCU DOGAN: Thanks,
for watching.
NICHOLAS GARNIER: Guys and
girls, for watching.
And we hope to see
you another time.
So it was Nicholas and Burcu,
live from Zurich.
All right, bye-bye.
BURCU DOGAN: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]